[Music]
no look is complete without the perfect
pair of earrings but earrings weren't
always just a fashion statement for
women did you know egyptian males were
actually among the first to wear
earrings
earrings date back more than 7 000 years
to ancient asia
in the 13th century ear piercings were
banned by the catholic church but they
made a comeback during the renaissance
in the 14th century
the early 1900s gave birth to the
clip-on earrings the 50s saw an uptick
in teenage ear piercings and the single
stud became the go-to look and we have
the memorable scene in the movie grease
to thank for that trend in the 60s and
70s we saw the invention of the piercing
gun in the 80s punk rock culture brought
on a wave of gauged and spike earrings
and in the 90s it was dominated by
bamboo hoops and nameplate earrings
today it's estimated that over 80
percent of americans have an ear
piercing one of the biggest trends in
the last decade is to go far beyond the
lobes and into the upper ear and the
late fashion icon coco chanel said
jewelry is an ornament so which earrings
are you rocking today
okay joining us now is a true superstar
in her own right she's a professional
piercer and jewelry designer who has
pierced the ears of everyone from
blake lively
charlize theron gwyneth paltrow
rihanna i mean i am so starstruck by
this woman i can't even handle it and
i'm going to get a meter right now it's
maria tash
[Applause]
now you have studios all over the world
now yeah i'm global we have studios in
the middle east as well as london and
dublin and miami we just opened dallas
is coming but it's around the world now
it's amazing i mean when rihanna comes
in and is like let's do something
what is it that
you look at and then where do you work
from what's that process i was really
honored because she's an organic client
and she had the metgala and she asked us
to design custom earrings for the met
gala so that got put out there was so
glad but um i love rihanna she takes a
lot of risks and likes a lot of what i
wear so i know she likes a lot of
movement i know what piercing she has so
it's about scaling things that she likes
to her ear and finding new wonderful
hidden placements like she just got the
hidden tash rook it's a piercing i
patented as well as attached helix and
other piercing i patented and so it's
great she takes a a lot of risks and
wears a lot of big bold things so i love
that
[Music]